do the game
again he's countering and trying to hit
okay
[Music]
okay let's
do
e
e for
all right so there's there's multiple
skills in
here uh
um so we
have um what what I call external skills
so we know how I Define the internal
okay so if I'm not doing that definition
of internal then you're doing external
okay so you you will have some paries
you see you have some
paries um if I if I if I have his Center
you see and you can feel I'm not moving
it right now but if you try to move it
you feel the the the stick there you
see go back to where you were here I am
again from the camera it looks like I'm
touch I'm just touching you I'm just
touching you but then you can see and
then you would feel like I there's
something there okay and I can of course
use it you see and then as you feel that
something there there then you'll try to
get out of it you see and so that will
be where maybe a Parry will come in you
see that so it starts at at the adhesion
level the seizure level and then as you
escape it there's a following level that
will take me now next to the
next in this case C you see okay do you
get it so that following That's What I
Call
following and it's very similar if I do
the following without any internal
it kind of looks like
this
okay following alone isn't what we do
it's more that I might have to follow
every once in a while you get it as
opposed to I follow
follow uh martially if I follow follow
eventually you're you're going to get
hit in the chest if you're only follow
following okay um and then there's no
energetic component to it if you're just
following anyways but martially
supplementing a actual iy
seizure with following then that's
something you have to do that okay so
you have to be careful that you're not
just on the outside and you keep going
like this kind of stuff you see even
though I'm touching it so at at Conta
back I already have you in that then you
try to I try to do something and you try
to get out of it
see and there's a mixture of following
where I am touching you and wherever
your hand goes I try to stay with it do
you see okay but unlike just straight
following like let's say I'm here and
you try to go around it then I'm on this
adhesion and you can't do that on the on
just pure following okay and then your
following skill gets
butter let's say I I use the adhesion to
get that tilt you see I'm going to have
a much easier time following a dude
that's trying to get there as opposed to
we're here and you're going around to
you see so as I get you off balance it's
easier to follow and to take you into
the face
you have to get out of there but I'm
always trying to put you you see back
here and you're playing with that hand
and I have mixture following I'm slowly
getting out when
do right there
follow
seize
e
e e
understand what seizure is that yeah it
feels like something but really what
what it is martially is you now have to
do something in response to what I'm
doing see so a lot of times when you get
him resist do your thing okay there we
go right here he he's barrel down see
you guys see how he's braced brace like
you were like a you you get it oh he's
doing something he's occupied and he's
occupied like that he's not attacking me
so you can't freak out when you have
that your opponent starts to use like a
bracing angle against you okay you're
still doing it it's still seized I can't
maybe I can't to him but he's still
seized do you understand that so they'll
start and then trying to shove him right
you can do things to it like you can egg
him on usually what I do is as as he
goes static does you see the arm is
right
so look when the guys are like you keep
trying to project you can't project well
maybe you can't pull then pull you
understand he sees take advantage of it
it's you as he gets start like oh you're
trying to do this it's you now you're
adding to this pressure instead of like
whoa he's really pushing
there but see now he pushes there I
could use it to yield with you guys
understand so you're trying to do your
thing he's doing
whatever so couple things like as let's
do that same push again I'm trying to
push him here well I can just take this
this
way right or you're like here you can
just drop and take away the ledge that
he was
using you guys got it don't don't start
contesting in
here that's not it
okay try these things
okay so when I follow and it's
external I'm just following the limb so
she moves her limb I just follow her
limb she moves her limb wherever I just
follow her then that's all I'm doing
okay
when I go
internal you for example I know I'm
either C which is a projection or I know
that I'm adhering if you pay attention
an adhering has some sort of pulling
aspect to it like she can't pull away or
or I can move her forward towards me you
see that you you don't really have an
adhesion if the two things aren't
pulling against each other it's just two
pieces of tape lying on each other isn't
really adhesion you see there's a
there's a a aspect of it that I need the
adhesion otherwise they'd come apart
okay so in order to project something
move something away from me it can't be
her arm has to be her Center and in
order to adhere something it has to be
connected to her Center and so when I
just follow her arms around she's trying
to hit me on the chest and I'm just
following her arms around you can see
that I'm only in the arms okay and no
matter how beautiful I make it
look I'm just in her arms but once I go
to the center then you can see this is
pushing on the
center this hand right here this hand
right here is pushing on the center and
you can see this hand over here and
pulling on this entry see so they're
touching but they're not just touching
here or touching there do you
see and that's what I call the seizure
okay so I have to always sees that and
now all of a sudden all her little hand
movements there are not so many of them
you see because her balance starts to go
you have to get that
stay there this hand to probably on the
camera looks like it's either doing
nothing or trying to lift her up but
it's pulling her out you
see from its contact
point now it's just waiting so this to
me this is following now I have her
again then she has to get out of it and
then not follow and here it is again in
her Center
right
here and then this hand over here is
doing the same pulling okay same this
way and this way but
here just like this one
is not following following when I have
to following to the next seizure
you have your mission
now that she looks totally different
right okay you
[Music]
we we had a comment like you know good
observation point is the use of Ledges
so you're like trying to get these
Ledges all the time like here you get
that ledge then this ledge you get you
know and you know you're just pushing on
Ledges and things like that and then you
can see the desire for the ledge and I
would you know because it's a fear
response it's a Will To Power
manifestation and it's just iau him his
mind is like I'm going to push on this
thing I'm going to overpower the thing
that's pushing on me but he can't push
on me unless I push on it okay and
likewise you know if he has if he has
Ledges on me you see and we're like
trying to get rid of these Ledges do you
see but if he has Ledges on me then I I
have it too it's like you stuck yourself
to me do you understand so like you're
in the contrast in the desire of wand
and the avoidance of that same wand from
the other side is telling you what's
going on instead of like okay I'm trying
to hit his chest he gets a ledge get
your Ledges cool now I go
here do you get what I'm saying so and
it comes all the time on the other way
too so if you pay
attention um let's say I'm the net so
he's trying to push in and then he goes
back to follow right and he's trying to
get a ledge right there do you see the
ledge is right there okay and that's the
that's the ledge that I can use on him
it's not necessarily that I go here he
comes on the inside yeah okay so he
comes on the inside come around I would
like to show the same one so the
audience knows what to look for you come
around right there okay he comes around
right there do you see and it's not it's
not that I go like whoa get rid of that
ledge like I can use that ledge see he
he's ping on me and so this freedom from
the from the dichotomy means the whole
dichotomy okay not me trying to get off
of it and avoid it being used against me
okay and when your when your mind is not
tonomous you can actually feel what it
is oh thank you you know you you you
adhere to me cool gool thank you I don't
have to seek it and likewise
this this move when I go here and he
comes around it's not I don't have to
block it you see it's not me blocking
something it's it's that's why it
doesn't ever look like it he comes
around here
here what what was that a block a throw
was it both was it neither one you see
and now you have the the tetralemma it
was a block it was a throw it was both a
block and thow and because it was both
it can't be neither either I don't know
what the hell it
was okay so as as you're working for
your Ledges maybe I don't know how I
don't think you could think of it on the
fly but sometimes you guys are getting
in a prolonged stuck on the ledge and I
think you might have enough time for the
intellect to go let me change this and
let me move the ledge that they're
trying to use against me okay and see
See it'll change things you'll get out
of those those looks like two Rams
budding heads you guys are locked horns
it's like oh if you lock to me then I
move you move see that's the idea
okay for
so let's think about it a little
differently so I know that from where
I'm touching i e can either push or pull
on your Center just
to keep it simple okay right and that's
a difference between the external
following I'm not touching your center
from your extremity
okay um and in this drill you're task
with um repositioning the Cent so the C
the center is in one place right and
then I'm I'm repositioning it from the
extremity okay how it is repositioned
from the uh its initial position is not
I don't ever choose
it just like because if I choose it I'm
going to choose it through the
dichotomous Mind through the ego
tripartite you see and just like that
ledge you know the the the the he's shut
me down by that
bicep uh hold and it's like no he's not
he's making himself glal do you get it
just by thinking about it differently or
experiencing it differently
okay and so likewise any way that you
make this Center move from its initial
position is the drill okay so you have
to be careful that as she's trying to do
this that I I only go that you see I
only go that you see cuz that's it
too because when I do this I don't have
you I follow till I get here now I touch
the center you see and then now I can
project but what we want to do is touch
the center from the
beginning as soon as I touch touch now
you have to do something do you see what
do you want to do okay then we go back
you guys get that as opposed to I'm here
okay now I
can touch C you have to do
something but don't think central
immediately on touch has to be pull it
doesn't have to be okay right so to be
clear I'm not sure you're following me
We Touch I'm going to describe what
your chosen pattern is
follow
Parry now you touch the center and then
you project away from it and what I just
demonstrated is I touch you see and it's
a pull but I don't want you to think in
that cuz I can touch and project right
on touch you see I do whatever
okay so what is it what is it I'm doing
it's not
really making the center do that it's
just touching the center you can just
touch the center any way you touch the
center then then they'll move to try to
regain their Center and when they move
to regain their Center I touch it again
do you get do do you get that it's just
a different way of thinking it it's not
that I'm doing something to you I I I'm
doing it do you see and I'm doing it and
then you're going to do
something and it's doing it again in
what you did you see as you as you're
doing that it's hitting your Center do
you see that okay and you go and oh oh
there it
is okay